début des années 80 en france le sydam
siècle on n'en finit plus de parler du
sida une maladie mystérieuse le sida
elle fait peur comme un cancer une
communauté est particulièrement touchée
celle des homosexuels
alors pour éviter de propager le virus
un arrêté signé en 1983 désormais les
personnes homosexuelles hommes et femmes
n'ont plus le droit de donner leur sang
à l'individu lambda se présenta centre
qui récupère le sens on lui fait remplir
un questionnaire est anonyme il ya une
question qui demande indirectement si on
est homosexuel
la communauté homo va lutter sans
relâche contre cette discrimination a
refusé mon sens parce que j'étais
homosexuel et
malgré que j'ai certifié absolument que
je ne vais pas de rapports
extraconjugaux
2002 première avancée les lesbiennes
sont autorisés à donner leur ton mais
les hommes eux toujours pas
c'est le cas de laurent drelon en 2007
cet homme découvre qu'il est fiché par
l'établissement français du sang car il
a indiqué son orientation sexuelle dans
un questionnaire le ffs lui a même
interdit de donner son sang jusqu'en
2002 178 moi je n'ai aucune maladie pape
sy n'a pas d'hépatite e rien du tout je
pas pourquoi je peux pas donner de sens
qu'à qu'a fait ce qu'il veut de cette
sécurité ça doit pas avoir recours à
cette addiction de sauver des vies
malgré ses colères rien ne change les
gains continuent d'être discriminées de
temps refusé parce que j'ai vu que je
tournais sexuelle donc j'étais refusé
sûr
mais ces appels finiront par être
entendu tout du moins en partie en 2016
un arrêté autorise les hommes
homosexuels à donner leur sang mais à
une condition celle de ne pas avoir eu
de rapports sexuels pendant un nom avant
le don par set
petite
contrainte d'abstinence en fait la
plupart d'entre nous sont toujours
effectivement exclu du don du sang en
2019 cette période d'abstinence a été
ramené à quatre mois puis à 0 en 2022
désormais les hommes homosexuels peuvent
donner leur sang dans les mêmes
conditions que les personnes
hétérosexuelles la fin de 39 ans de
discriminations
[Musique]